let's pull this picture we got here we
got a tweet from andrew doyle take a
look at this it's terrifying so um
greg you're from the uk right is that
yes i am what what is this where is this
location it looks it looks like well
there's a double decker bus there it
looks like it's regent street looks like
south looking down regent street which
crosses oxford street but it also looks
like um i don't know it's it's
emblematic somewhat of uh
for those for those are just listening
it is probably what like a hundred
el like pride intersex flags
five five flags per row ten flat ten
rows
at least fifty at least well it cuts
around the corner so you can't actually
see but you got one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven 12 13
that can be seen right so uh
quite a bit more than 50.
65 at the very least
yeah this is uh well i what i think
maybe you were thinking this greg i'm
not sure correct me if if i'm wrong but
this looks like i thought this could
have been a picture from nazi germany
that was colorized and then the flat the
nazi flags were superimposed with pride
flags
because it's the sa it is freaking
terrifying how a bunch of i don't want
no i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
generalize ideological flags being flown
so i have a question though
is it overreact is it is that an
overreaction because i was facetiously
tweeting on twitter like it's literally
nazi gemini i don't care about the pride
flags well you know i look at what when
i go ahead just real quick i'm wondering
if you've ever seen an ideological flag
flown to this degree in the uk like this
never but
no and what what it makes me think about
is the union jack the flag of england so
it was about 15
16 years ago i went back to england and
you know i'd been away for a while
because i live in america and american
citizen now and i mentioned flying the
union jack the flag of it and oh no you
can't do that you can't do that you you
it's a symbol of racism now i'm like
hang on a minute the union jack is a
symbol of race when did that happen you
know i grew up my grand my grandfather
fought in the second half so look at all
my grandfather but he did he fought in
the second world war you know and he
lost his firstborn son during the second
world war
like
why can't we be patriotic why can't we
talk about you know the pride for the
people who give their lives and to to
afford us our freedoms and and i look at
this and i think well it's not so much
that flag it doesn't really really mean
that much to me it's what flag should be
flying there and if it were flying there
um what we would be thinking what we
would be told to be thinking you know we
well we can't celebrate that flag let's
let's read andrew doyle's tweets uh he
said for some these flags represent
diversity and inclusion but for many
they symbolize an ideological movement
that is hostile to gay people and
women's rights opposes free speech
legitimizes violence and bullying and
hounds people out of their jobs if they
fail to conform yeah that's right uh
there was a comic shop
near me um a while ago and i remember i
went there and it was cool and that
stuff and i bought it one day i came
back and they had a big flag one of
these flags in there and i was like i'm
not gonna go there again because these
are the people that have defended
murder and violence
if i went to a comic shop and they had a
swastika flag i also would be like i'm
not gonna go there because these are
people who have justified violence
murder and harmed other people and i
don't trust people of this extremist
ideology
if i'm working if i'm if i'm on the job
and i'm working politically and i have
security and stuff i have no problem
interviewing antifa or alt-right or
whatever but i'm not going to go to an
establishment that flies that flag
because it's legitimately an extremist
organization
flying the flag of an extremist ideology
not interested you know going to new
york this past weekend for the event
every single business was flying the
flag
you come out to west virginia and
surprise surprise even small towns out
here fly these flags but these flags
they do not represent
pride and love and inclusion
they are flown by people who have thrown
molotov cocktails through buildings they
are flown by people who have
brutally beaten journalists in the
street and who advocate for executions
assassinations and revolution they are
political extremists
now if you agree and bend the knee to
the ideology you'll be fine
but if you stand up defiantly and say
what you did to that man in provo utah i
think it was a man shot in the arm
driving his car for no reason is wrong
and they say it was for a good cause
what you did to david dorn was not good
they say don't you dare defy us
it's like okay these people are
psychopaths and the flag of a psychotic
death cult is being flown now you want
to come out and say that donald trump
supporters are a death cult and all that
stuff and i'm like dude
there is there's no institutional power
behind the q and on people none
maybe maybe some high profile people but
nothing relevant in the in the modern
conservative movement libertarian and
and with moderates joining the ranks
it's people being like i think people
should have a right to choose in their
own state how they live
versus the left saying the federal
government should impose our will over
the entirety of the country one's
extremist
seeking politics based on domination and
the other is seeking politics based on
moderation
unfortunately it seems like the
moderation political side is going to
get crushed because they don't seek to
dominate their opponents
i think there are some people who who
maybe fly this flag and believe in
inclusion and believe that they're
believing it but it's like a friend of
mine who
she was she was ultra woke and she was
on the women's march and now she's kind
of you know
she's come
she's broke through that belief system
let's say she doesn't have that uh that
ideology that's like everyone on that
side is bad and she's actually seen
behind the behind the curtain that you
know the mainstream media is not all
it's purporting to be and it is a lot of
propaganda so i think there's people
that do you think there are people who
are just ignorant who do you
want you know want to support because i
have nothing against the flow when i see
the flag i don't think bad things oh
well the swastika it was the wheel of
life it's the hindu
flower of life it's an ancient symbol of
peace and the turning of growth and
death and life and rebirth and it was a
beautiful symbol and the nazis believed
in the purity and the wonder of germany
it was that's what the people believed
in is the greatness of the fatherland
and then of course the psychopath drug
addict twisted it
yeah that guy was on meth
like crazy hitler
he was also deranged from the war he was
just a broken mentally broken and this
is this is the issue
uh
i'm not i think people need to
understand too the the refusal to see
historical analogs is based on the fact
that things haven't gotten that bad yet
that's that's insane
so when you have nazi germany i i think
it is a bit silly to constantly use them
as the example but they were so
egregious but why don't we use communist
uh russia and the revolution and that's
more akin to the leftist revolution and
they had their flag and they had their
symbol the sickle and the hammer and
they executed the communism killed over
100 million people
only lasted 67 years and look how much
death destruction and genocide they
waged and people flew their flags
people thought it was for the good for
the better they said it's we're fighting
for the work the workers and we're
making the world a better place and
we're dealing with the oppressors
and they were ruled by psychopaths the
average person who flew the flag
they're not evil they're stupid but
stupid people in large quantities are
extremely dangerous you know michael
malus talks about
he says how could anyone be blackpilled
these people are so incredibly stupid
and i somewhat agree with him but i will
point out zombies are also stupid and a
hundred thousand zombies marching
towards you is a force to be reckoned
with that's what we're dealing with
people flying this flag are just like i
don't know whatever
do as you're told don't don't
resist and you'll be fine you won't be
they'll still come for you and cancel
you no matter what you do there was that
author recently who made an off-color
joke or something had to apologize and
then even though he apologized they came
after him again that's the story
tales all this time
the people are flying these flags
because they think everyone else thinks
it's popular no one actually knows or
cares what it means it's a it's a
mishmash of nonsense i i'm willing to
bet in fact when i was in new york
people are flying the rainbow flag and
that's considered offensive now
but they didn't know that so they were
just because the rainbow flags
considered defensive yes why is that
it's exclusionary to trans people and
black people see i mean there you go
it's like you know and now we see
martina navratilova's comment
you saw what you said to me what she uh
i said that um
given that there's a higher uh history
of mental illness among the left
and that trans people have a higher rate
of suicide red flag laws will be used
against them more often than against the
right and then she angrily responded
that i was an idiot that i was an a-hole
that i was making these things up and it
wasn't true
and i just it's crazy to me because she
sounds dangerous someone needs to well
the police need it i'm kidding it takes
you two seconds to just google it and
what do you get 3 000 articles all these
different studies showing the left has
higher rates of mental illness it's a
fact
it is an established scientific fact
that the more liberal and left-leaning
you are the higher your rates of mental
illness
i didn't make that up
she was arrogant she was ignorant and
that's exactly the problem
she just saw what i said said how dare
you i'm angry
that's it that happens a lot and to your
point about communism and the hammer and
sickle you know there are a lot of
people still we we do you know the false
glamour of our idolatry and our
iconography i mean we think it's cool
but we forget at times uh that you know
millions of people were slaughtered uh
you know during
these
yeah i mean so you know i i was
suggesting that people shouldn't be you
know should people be glorifying the
hammer and sickle we don't glorify the
swastika i mean you know
that's that that and that is something
that uh is a failure of our education
our culture and our institutions and now
our institutions are co-opted so they'll
never come out against it but the sickle
and hammer represents 100 150 million
dead i mean the things this systemic and
systematic execution of people and what
people on the left i love this the
occupy wall street people
they don't understand they're the
bourgeois the bourgeoisie
that does not mean the wealthy elites it
means the middle class and the
proletariat the workers they don't
realize they are the people they are
advocating for their own wealth
distribution redistribution or being
thrown in the gulags
yeah no it's true i've had that i've had
that conversation with people who are
very wealthy and consider themselves to
be on the left like no you don't
understand like you are the bourgeoisie
no no it's not extremely wealthy it's
middle class
extremely wealthy compared to a large
pers like the vast majority of the world
population these these kids
these young people who are socialists
and they make 50 60 000 a year i'm like
you are exactly who marx wanted to get
rid of
and stalin stalin's a better example
because he was the one who actually did
it
yeah they don't understand the
intelligentsia these people the laptop
class
when if you were in
russia i mean that's who they came for
first the commune already has a buzzfeed
article writer that's right um
yeah you you mentioned the fact that the
hammer and sickle is not as taboo and
it's funny because you'll see a lot of
lefties flying that flag or putting in
their bio as if that's edgy or
interesting but it's basically always
been allowed at least throughout my
lifetime the only way i remember
communism really being addressed was
with reference to the quote unquote
overreaction from it in the united
states i even remember in history class
in public school when they were
explaining communism to us of course
they mentioned that many people were
killed but they also talked about the
poor people who were supposedly helped
by it and we were kind of given both
sides there which is really interesting
can you imagine if a public school
teacher said well let's give you like
both sides of this whole nazi thing
right we did
fix the economy and mussolini made the
trains run on time yeah and so
yeah if i care about those things
exactly and so
i gotta say
it probably has something to do with the
fact that many people in uh media and in
academia are and have been communists
four decades
yeah people are commenting like mccarthy
was right well and it's funny because
people people are shocked when you say
that it's like well why would that not
be the case
fear of communism has always always
always in every single instance that
shows up in media been scoffed at or
laughed at
it's just a moral panic why were people
afraid of that ideology that killed
hundreds of millions of people how silly
you made a funny comment earlier about
the feature dystopia and the flags of
the rainbows and stuff
oh was this when was this just a moment
ago oh my gosh yeah before the show
started no i was just saying like for
historians to look back on all the
tyrannical systems throughout all of
history and then they see ours and the
flag is like rainbows happy fun like all
of the other tyrannical regimes have
these very intimidating symbols and i
was like happy times the swastika was a
beautiful it wasn't intimidating in the
beginning it was the wheel of light it
was it was a beautiful symbol and maybe
it's it's because of the context but
also at the same time like a swastika
like that black symbol inside of a white
circle on a red flag does look
intimidating
so so this is an interesting point man
like it's funny that you bring up the
rainbows and stuff
but uh
i went to an antique shop when i was in
texas and they had so many swastikas all
over the place
and this is in austin and i was like
it's trump's america you said yeah i was
like i was like hey hey ho ho antique
shop has got to go and yeah no i'm
kidding but i asked them i was like hey
how can you be all the swastika stuff
and they said
in the early 1900s
it was considered a symbol of good luck
and healing and all these good things
that's why the nazis took it
so
you could go around the u.s in on the
south side of chicago where i grew up
there's a house
that had a swastika it was a two-story
building a swastika on the top and wood
blocks were hammered in to make it a
square
but you could see it and you knew it was
a swastika i thought you were going to
say there's a swastika on the house and
my old argentinian neighbor insisted it
was just a peace symbol
you see it on like buildings in downtown
chicago too in the loop you'll see like
just carved into the stone masonry
swastikas all along the top
in 19 it wasn't until world war ii the
symbol became something else and they
inverted it the the actual symbol is
that in the mirror yeah that's right so
just think about that
everybody is putting up these good luck
symbols all over the place and then all
along comes nazi germany and it wasn't
until we learned of what they were doing
that we were like whoa that symbolized
all this really really bad stuff
so historians look back at it and
they're like look how evil and awful
this symbol is they'll they may do the
same that exact thing to these flags
they're not going to look at it like it
was it was pretty and happy they're
going to look back and be like wow how
evil and disgusting who knows wasn't
there the party originally that was it
the german national socialist workers
national association what it was that's
what
yeah the german workers party or
whatever right yeah
yeah but they were like their version of
socialism was based on like race
so it was like
is it identitarianism it wasn't really
socialism some people want to say it is
but it's like it's like racial identity
and economics is something slightly
different racial identitarian socialists
that sounds a little bit familiar that's
what i'm talking about and it's not even
a joke that's true 100 percent
let me put it this way too sorry these
flags represent the exact same political
ideology as the nazis yep not
not in the sense of what they've done or
want to do
it it covers identitarianism yeah they
are identitarian flags that your race or
or uh
you know so it it's a flag about
identitarianism
now how they implement it how they feel
about certain races is different but
it's an identitarian flag that's what i
mean to say
i think that's what the nazi stood for
youtube keeps telling me to inject ads
they're like don't do it
with the healthy aging support of
collagen
another aspect that worries me as we
talk about the allegories between the
flags being flown ideologies being being
pushed is the the economy
flailing right now like it was in 1928
29 right before hitler
you tell me you're gonna fix it you tell
me who the enemy is and i'll follow you
anywhere because i'm starving el
salvador is looking pretty good right
about now well it's never it was
inevitable that was gonna happen with
the economy but i'm still surprised that
the alarm bells aren't real they don't
seem to be ringing in the press that
much it's like oh there's stuff they're
in on it the press is in on it that's
what
i don't have a paper trail but that is
certainly what it seems like is
happening have you uncovered much of a
paper trail what do you mean between
global economy and the u.s media
apparatus
cnn comcast do you mean like how jim
cramer was telling people to buy up
stocks right before the 08 crash or how
he's like continually telling to buy
when then the market correctly and
that's it again recently doing this well
i don't think that's just in his blood
isn't it no
the the media sells you out and lies to
you the corporate press and the elites
along with it i mean come on
when i was on stage at the mines event i
wrapped up by saying you know uh trayvon
martin's story was fabricated they nbc
edited the audio to make it seem like
zimmerman was racist michael brown hands
up don't shoot that wasn't true justice
millet that wasn't true russia gate
ukraine gate uh uh joe biden started his
campaign the the um the very fine people
hoax like it's all lies and it always
props up the establishment politicians
and their agenda what i like now and
what i think is different than 1929 is
it was mass media was new then they had
radio and they just began like
television and video or video and stuff
uh film and so they were they all bought
in they thought it was real even war of
the worlds that orson wellesley people
some people i've heard thought that it
was we were actually being attacked by
aliens people didn't question the media
like hitler had his minister of
propaganda and no one i mean people i
don't think really quit they just saw it
they were brainwashed now we know that
it's brainwashing and so we're at least
aware
and so i think that's why there's so
much pushback like what you're saying
earlier about glenn young and getting
elected people being able to see the the
manipulation a lot more effectively than
100 years ago thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you